el estado de oxidación indica la
distribución general digamos de los
electrones y otra forma de llamar a los
estados de oxidación es el número de
oxidación y por supuesto este concepto
se cubre mucho en los cursos de química
general y voy a empezar digamos con con
la forma de asignar el número de
oxidación de la forma como se hace en
química general y luego vamos a
saltarnos a una forma de asignar este
número más más como se hace en química
orgánica ok y es mucho más útil cuando
estamos trabajando con moléculas
orgánicas y la cosa es que muchas
personas se se olvidan que el número de
oxidación es bueno más bien que la
electro negatividad está involucrada en
el número de oxidación así que les voy a
mostrar unos cuantos ejemplos de eso ok
y otras definiciones de química general
son los conceptos de oxidación que en
este caso es un incremento en el estado
de oxidación en el número de oxidación
verdad mientras que la otra definición
es la reducción que es la disminución en
el estado de oxidación y puse aquí
digamos unos unas siglas con los cuales
puede uno recordar fácilmente a qué se
refiere la oxidación o reducción por
ejemplo si nosotros tenemos una pérdida
de electrones eso es oxidación pérdida
de electrones es oxidación verdad por
eso le ponemos peor que podría ser
ganancia de electrones es la reducción
así que aquí tenemos ya una reacción de
hecho tenemos metano que se está digamos
está reaccionando con el oxígeno para
producir nos bióxido de carbono y agua
esencialmente este es una reacción de
combustión verdad entonces vamos a
tratar de ver qué pasa con los estados
de oxidación de cada uno
elementos ver cuáles se oxidan y cuáles
se reducen y lo primero que vamos a
hacer es de la forma que ya lo memoriza
este como se hace en química general y
después vamos a utilizar la digamos la
técnica o el método de la química
orgánica ok entonces lo que lo primero
que vamos a hacer es seguir las reglas
de asignación de los números de
oxidación verdad y esas reglas nos dicen
que el hidrógeno siempre tiene una carga
positiva y solo una verdad entonces el
hidrógeno tiene una carga más 1 y en
este caso para el metano como tenemos 4
hidrógenos entonces tenemos aquí una
carga positiva de 4 ahora bien sabemos
que estas moléculas siempre deben estar
bien balanceadas eso quiere decir que
para que el metano esté balanceado el
carbono debe tener una carga de menos 4
entonces el carbono tiene una carga
negativa de 4 verdad y entonces este
metano ya está muy bien este balanceado
ahora qué pasa con el oxígeno cuando se
encuentra en su estado gaseoso que es el
o2
verdad simplemente nos olvidamos de
cuantos tenemos y para que esto esté
balanceado cada oxígeno debe tener una
carga cero verdad debe estar de este
debe tener una carga neutra ahora bien
también sabemos que el oxígeno en este
tipo de condiciones tiene una carga
negativa de 2 cada oxígeno en este caso
tenemos 2 oxígenos de carga menos 2 eso
nos da una carga negativa de 4 entonces
para que el dióxido de carbono esté bien
balanceado aquí debemos tener una carga
positiva de 4 eso quiere decir que el
carbono en este caso debe tener una
carga de más 4 muy bien
vámonos finalmente con el agua y este es
muy sencillo porque el oxígeno debe
tener una carga negativa de 2 un número
una carga de menos 2 y entonces el
hidrógeno para poder balancear el agua
cada uno de esto o bueno en total debe
tener una carga positiva de 2 pero
tenemos dos hidrógenos quiere decir que
cada uno tiene una carga positiva
1 entonces si nos fijamos en aquella
asustan o en aquellos elementos que
incrementaron su estado de oxidación o
su número de oxidación podemos ver que
el carbono pasó de menos 4 a más 4
entonces tuvimos un incremento en el
estado de oxidación verdad entonces el
carbono podemos decir que se óxido
por otro lado por otro lado tenemos que
encontrar algo que se haya reducido es
decir alguien que haya disminuido en su
estado de oxidación y podemos ver que el
oxígeno y el oxígeno estaba tenía una
carga neutra y llegó a tener una carga
de menos 2 entonces disminuyó su estado
de oxidación y por lo tanto podemos
decir que el oxígeno se redujo así que
esa es la forma digamos de química
general en la que uno puede calcular los
estados de oxidación pero ahora vamos a
útil a verlo de una forma más como en
química orgánica así que vamos a dibujar
algunas estructuras de puntos y checar
la electrón negatividad
elementos entonces vamos a empezar
primero con el metano el metano es muy
sencillo de pintar tenemos un carbono
unido a cuatro hidrógenos verdad tenemos
esto unido a cuatro hidrógenos y solo
para poder hacer esto mucho más sencillo
voy a poner los electrones como lo hemos
estado haciendo en los vídeos de carga
formal verdad que están involucrados en
estos enlaces covalentes ahora ahora
vamos a pensar en las tendencias de
electro negatividad que tienen estos dos
átomos bueno el átomo de carbono y el
átomo de hidrógeno y si recuerdas estas
tendencias el carbono tiende a ser más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno así
que vamos vamos a hacer vamos a tratarlo
de la siguiente forma como si estos
enlaces fueran enlaces iónicos aunque
técnicamente son enlaces covalentes de
verdad así que si tuviéramos un enlace
iónico en esta parte ok entonces si esto
fuera un enlace iónico como el carbón es
mucho más electrón negativo va a robarse
todos los electrones de este hidrógeno
entonces
digamos si ponemos algo de la siguiente
forma si ponemos aquí nuestro carbono
entonces de cada hidrógeno va a robarse
sus electrones entonces de esta forma el
carbono aunque aunque estaban aquí
digamos en un enlace covalente quiere
decir que se va a robar el electrón del
hidrógeno y va a completarse de esta
siguiente forma verdad va a tener 8
electrones alrededor mientras que los
hidrógenos van a quedar alrededor del
carbono digamos solitos verdad entonces
le robó todos sus electrones ahora bien
para calcular digamos el número de
oxidación o el estado de oxidación vamos
a utilizar la siguiente fórmula que es
muy sencilla va a ser el número de
electrones de valencia alrededor de un
átomo alrededor de un átomo y eso
simplemente lo podemos saber a partir de
en qué grupo se encuentra en la tabla
periódica y luego le restamos
el número de electrones de electrones
alrededor del mismo átomo alrededor
del átomo pero este número de electrones
esto es después de considerar o de tomar
en cuenta la electro negatividad ok la
electro negatividad para este caso del
carbono que es lo que vamos a tener el
número de electrones de valencia del
carbono es justamente 4 verdad ya lo
hemos visto varias veces ahora restamos
cuántos electrones tenemos alrededor del
carbono ya una vez que consideramos la
electro negatividad como si fueran
enlaces iónicos y éstos nos dan 8
electrón o de electrones alrededor eso
quiere decir que tenemos un resultado de
menos 4 verdad ahora bien qué ocurre con
el caso del hidrógeno el hidrógeno tiene
un electrón de valencia pero alrededor
del hidrógeno después de considerar la
electro negatividad tenemos 0 electrones
eso nos da una carga positiva de 1
verdad entonces esto es muy sencillo y
de hecho lo podemos verificar a cada
verdad
justamente como lo hicimos en la forma
clásica tenemos que el carbono tiene una
carga de menos 4 mientras que el
hidrógeno tiene carga más 1 verdad
entonces en efecto coinciden estas dos
formas de hacerlo
ahora podrías estar pensando que esta
forma de asignar el estado de oxidación
es muy similar a la carga formal y
realmente lo es es extremadamente
similar a la carga formal la única
diferencia es que cuando estamos
haciendo los números de oxidación
estamos tratando los enlaces como si
fueran enlaces iónicos y estamos
considerando el concepto de la
electrones negatividad cuando estamos
haciendo cargas formales no los estamos
tratando como enlaces iónicos ok
en ese caso pues simplemente son enlaces
covalentes y comparten los electrones
vamos a hacer el caso del oxígeno el
caso del oxígeno en este en esta parte
de aquí tenemos 2 oxígenos que están
unidos verdad y esa estructura se ve de
la siguiente forma tenemos 2 oxígenos 2
oxígenos y tienen un enlace doble entre
ellos verdad ahí está entonces cómo
calculamos el número de oxidación o el
estado de oxidación
cada uno de estos oxígenos pues si
tratáramos estos como enlaces iónicos
tendríamos el oxígeno cada uno de estos
oxígenos y nos preguntamos cuál es más
electrón negativo pues en realidad es la
misma sustancia
perdón es el mismo elemento entonces son
igual de electrón negativos quiere decir
que cada uno de ellos se va a quedar con
un par de electrones verdad aquí
teníamos sus dos pares de electrones
solitarios que van acá y cada uno de
ellos se queda con un par de electrones
entonces hacemos esta cuenta con esta
fórmula cuál es el número de electrones
de valencia alrededor del del oxígeno y
esos son 6
esos son 6 verdad siempre tiene 6
electrones de valencia y ahora restamos
cuántos electrones tiene alrededor de
este átomo después de haber considerado
la electro negatividad y son justamente
6 lo mismo pasa para este caso verdad
entonces la carga que o más bien el
número de oxidación que le podemos
asignar es el
y esto coincide nuevamente con lo que ya
teníamos verdad ahí lo tienen entonces
todo está funcionando muy bien ok ahora
vamos a hacer el último caso digamos
bueno no es el último pero es el último
ejemplo qué vamos a hacer qué pasa con
el dióxido de carbono
entonces el dióxido de carbono lo
podemos poner de la siguiente forma
tenemos un carbono y está unido con un
enlace doble a un oxígeno y unido con
otro enlace doble al otro oxígeno verdad
entonces nuevamente nos preguntamos cuál
es más electro negativo si el carbono o
el oxígeno y sabemos qué
bueno sabemos que el oxígeno es más
electro negativo que el carbono entonces
quiere decir que cada oxígeno se va a
robar estos electrones del carbono
entonces cómo se vería esto nos quedaría
el carbono digamos aquí y este oxígeno
este oxígeno tenía aquí estos dos pares
de electrones solitarios y estos dos
electrones se los va a robar del carbono
verdad o más bien va a quedar de esta
forma lo mismo ocurre con este oxígeno
tiene sus dos pares de electrones
solitarios y va a robarse los electrones
del carbono ya que es más electro
negativo entonces si queremos calcular
el estado de oxidación del carbono
simplemente recordamos que su el número
de electrones de valencia del carbono
son 4 y alrededor de este carbono
quedaron 0 verdad 0 electrones por lo
tanto su estado de oxidación es de más 4
ahora que ocurre con el oxígeno tiene 6
electrones de valencia pero restamos
cuántos electrones tiene al fin
de este análisis tiene 2 468 entonces su
carga será de menos 2 muy bien más bien
su estado de oxidación lo mismo ocurre
para este oxígeno y podemos verificar
que esto coincide con el análisis
anterior que habíamos hecho verdad que
el carbono tenía una carga un estado de
oxidación más 4 y el oxígeno de menos 2
entonces esto funciona muy bien
así que pudimos ver que en efecto el
carbono pasó de un estado de oxidación
-4 a un estado de oxidación más 4 eso
quiere decir que perdió electrones
verdad aquí tenía 8 electrones 8
electrones y terminó con 0 electrones
entonces perdimos electrones en cambio
el oxígeno
tuvo una reducción verdad el oxígeno
tenía 6 electrones y terminó con 8
electrones entonces hubo una ganancia de
electrones ahora bien el carbono en
realidad no es que sólo tenga estos
estados de reducción de hecho puede
tener todos estos de menos 4 - 3 - 2 - 1
0 1 2 3 y 4 son todos los estados de
oxidación que puede tener el carbono
y entonces tú dirás bueno para que
tenemos dos métodos de hacerlo si
realmente el primero a lo mejor resultó
ser más fácil para esta reacción pero
como veremos en el próximo vídeo cuando
estemos haciendo digamos estamos
calculando o trabajando con moléculas
orgánicas mucho más complicadas vamos a
necesitar la segunda forma la forma
digamos de la química orgánica donde
dibujamos las estructuras de puntos y
consideramos la electro negatividad y
utilizando esta fórmula que pusimos aquí
arriba vamos a poder calcular el estado
de oxidación de los elementos